Hello, everyone!
Let's hear some cheers!
Hello, all the Dragoons!
Who are we here to see today?
We are here to see...
Wow!
I know you've been waiting for a long time.
I won't say too much.
Let's say her name again.
Hello,
everyone!
We are here in Hong Kong!
Hello, everyone!
Hello, Doki!
Welcome to Hong Kong ACG!
Hello, welcome to Hong Kong ACG!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy to be here.
Yeah, I am!
It's like 3.30 a.m., but yeah, I am.
I choked down a can of coffee before I got here because it's 3.30 in the morning.
We love the dessert!
Did you see your fans over there?
The Dragoons?
Make some noise, guys!
There are so many!
There are so many Hong Kong Dragoons!
There are lots of people.
Half of the venue's people are over here for meeting you, actually.
So...
I can't hear you.
Why is the mic muted?
I don't know what the MC said.
Can you hear me right now?
I can hear you.
You want me to speak English on Cantonese?
I can do both.
I'm going to do both because my Cantonese level is like a third grade level.
So I will speak English and some Cantonese.
Okay, good.
I can hear you.
No problem.
Actually, I'm telling you that half of the venue's people over here are meeting you.
What do you think for HKACG in this event?
Is this your first time?
Well, I went to the ACGHK when I was young.
It was my first convention when I was young.
I was very happy.
I didn't even think I would be a guest here.
The first time was a guest.
Okay, so...
Actually, I want to ask all of you what is Doki's best at?
What is Doki's best at?
Can you hear me?
Yes!
Okay, so...
What are we going to do next, Doki?
Oh, so we're going to be playing a little bit of Apex today.
Some of the draggoons are very lucky to play with me.
Yes, some lovely draggers have a chance to play with you today.
So, we're going to play Apex with Doki today.
We saw the three of us who bought the bundle.
We're going to play with the friends who are in the lead.
Let's play from the first round.
Pick your draggons.
Who wants to play with me?
Who is good?
Who knows how to play?
Okay, those who picked by Doki, at least five hero names.
Okay, at least five hero names.
Okay, I saw the first one.
The first one was raised her hand.
There's one guy with a rabbit hair over there.
Over there?
Yeah, that guy.
Okay, him.
And one more.
You want girl?
I saw a very pretty lady over here.
She's dressed like a young...
Okay.
Let's give them a round of applause.
Actually, they came to this stage because they were very nervous.
I saw so many people.
I'm very nervous.
I'm nervous too.
I'll play the Hong Kong Pink.
I don't know.
The Hong Kong Pink is over 200.
I just saw it.
Let me pick up a pretty coser.
Give her a round of applause.
You'll carry me, right?
You're in Hong Kong.
You'll carry me.
Let me do a little bit of interview.
What's your name?
Her name is Zi Mao Yuan.
I don't know how to translate in English.
Is Mao Mao?
Nicco Maloo.
The girl's name is Nicco Maloo.
Oh, Mao Mao.
Yes, Mao Mao.
What's your name?
Thomas.
Let's give Thomas a round of applause.
Thomas, have you played Apex before?
How long have you played Apex?
I've been playing for a while.
Are you confident that you won't You're very confident that you won't get caught.
You won't get caught!
I won't save you.
You're confident, right?
Yes, I am.
I'm very tired.
Why is that?
I know Thomas will carry you.
Because he said he won't get caught.
Thomas will carry us.
Let Thomas carry us.
They believe you will carry them, right?
Yeah, I believe.
If he dies, I won't raise him.
Let's start the game.
Alright, alright.
Let me add them.
I'm going to add them.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Actually, let's take a picture with you right now.
You guys are even in my lobby.
Oh, I want Apex.
Caustic?
Okay.
Oh.
I'll save you guys.
I'll do lifeline.
If you guys die, I can save you guys.
Do you know what I was playing just now?
I was playing Overwatch, not Apex.
I don't know if I can do it.
I was playing Overwatch just now.
Thomas, Thomas promised to carry everyone.
No worries, Doki.
Okay, no, okay, good, good.
I don't need to shoot.
Thomas can do it.
I don't need to shoot?
Okay.
I'll feed Thomas all the ammo.
You can give it to Thomas.
Okay, Thomas, who are you?
It's your turn, Thomas.
Thomas, you're Valkyrie or Caustic?
Who are you?
Oh, they can't hear the mic.
Can't they hear it?
They can't hear it.
Okay, you can start.
He's Caustic, I'm Valkyrie.
Thomas is now.
Oh, Loba?
Rave?
Thomas is definitely Rave.
Definitely him.
He's Valkyrie.
He's Valkyrie, no, he's Rave.
Right?
Okay, fighting.
Alright, Thomas.
If you die, you're bad.
Whoever dies first is the worst player.
Oh, shit, that's a lot of people.
Okay.
Alright.
Thomas, Lila, who be now?
Thomas.
Um, you're down.
Thomas, who die?
Who be now?
Like, die all day.
He said he don't know.
They didn't see who be.
Thomas!
He said he have no idea.
Thomas, you said you carry.
You don't know?
Thomas!
Let's jump right now.
Alright, let's go.
How many people?
One squad.
No.
Okay.
200 ping.
No!
Don't die!
I don't have a gun!
I have longbow.
Longbow and 200 ping.
Thomas, please.
Thomas!
Thomas, no!
What's going on, Thomas?
Thomas, what happened?
I'm lifelined!
Don't be so nervous.
Okay.
Thomas, I'm lifelined!
I have zero ammo!
Okay, I know what Thomas means.
He carry everyone to another place.
Yes, he carry everyone to die.
Okay.
Thank you, Thomas.
We love you so much.
Thomas, good job.
Oh, there's two team.
Two team.
Okay, I'm two team of the...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Wow!
Oh, shit.
I don't have ammo.
Goodbye.
One more chance.
I don't have ammo.
It's okay.
Warm up, warm up.
Keep going.
One more chance.
Thomas.
Okay, Thomas, how much damage did you take?
Hey!
Thomas, you're 45!
Hi!
He has...
Neko has 83, you're 45.
Don't go.
We give him one more chance, okay?
Okay.
He said he's done.
Nervous.
Maybe Thomas, you're playing Lifeline, Thomas.
I'm doing Wraith.
Ashu is doing Bangalore.
Bangalore is better.
Thomas, you're doing Healer.
You can't do it.
I'll ask Thomas again.
Are you ready?
No.
He said he's not already, but we don't care, okay?
Okay, warm up, warm up.
They said they didn't ready, but we don't care.
Okay, just go.
It's okay.
We're ready.
We're so ready.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Where should I take him?
Me?
I'm not taking him.
I won't jump.
I'll take him.
Let it be.
Okay, I'm just going to jump.
I'm going to jump.
Okay.
So what should I do?
Oh.
I got him!
Here, no one's here
Thomas, but we don't want to fight other people Thomas is still very scared
What are you scared of?
I think somebody landed labs Let's get some guns and fight them Labs are very dangerous
I won't die I'm just going to steal their loot
Let go, I'm here!
It's okay, let go It's okay, Thomas is the one we're supposed to be judging, not you
Alright, let's see I don't know if there's actually people there so I'm scared Alright, let's see Is there people here?
Eh?
No one Okay, we're okay, safe It's safe, don't worry Where would people be fighting?
Thomas, why are you hitting us here?
No one's here Thomas, you're always...
They're sightseeing Yeah, it's like Donkey Kong's Adventure We're just sightseeing We're the enemy Thomas is showing you guys Oh, they're going to rank Actually, he is showing you like...
Guys, we're going to rank up Where's Thomas?
Oh my god!
We got plus points guys!
Top ten!
Alright, uh, most likely there should be people.
Should be people like maybe Cage?
I'm going to go to Cage.
I died and Lifeline will respawn.
That's good.
Where are people?
Oh my god.
I am sightseeing.
Everybody's dying.
Oh look, there's a box.
Alright, oh there's two boxes.
Oh, oh, I'll turn on.
Turn on, no, oh yeah.
Turn on.
Alright.
Wait, where is Thomas?
I saw him!
Where is Thomas?
Why are you over there?
Didn't see him in a long, long time.
Oh, people here.
Okay.
Alright,
I'm running out of ammo.
Okay, I have another Arc Star.
Whoa, Thomas, help me!
Thomas, we need help!
Oh, I got ammo!
It's okay, goodbye Thomas.
No!
Okay, okay.
Let's give them a hand.
Give them a round of applause.
Okay.
Okay, oh, you know what?
You're okay because we know your place.
Thomas, 66, really?
Okay, so, um, thank you Tommy, Thomas.
Thank you Thomas and Neko.
And thank you, thank you, doggies also.
Thank you Thomas for the, like, AKS adventure.
It's okay, Thomas, you did your best.
You should have been more humble, Thomas.
I'm sorry.
Let's invite them back on stage.
Yes, be careful.
Be careful.
Is there anyone else who wants to be with doggies?
Anyone else?
I'll be really nice to you guys this time, I swear.
Okay, let's play one more round, doggies.
Let's pick some more guys that really play Neko.
I think Apex is very good, I think.
Let me try.
Let me see.
Alright, yeah, front row, that guy.
This guy?
That guy over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How many years have you played Apex?
Let me choose for you.
Can you name actually five heroes?
Three years?
Five heroes?
Can you name them?
Okay, let's go.
Name five legends.
Yeah, I'll help you pick some.
Then you help me pick.
Let me choose any girls.
Any girls?
Like...
Hello?
Where are you from?
Oh, no, actually.
How many years have you played Apex?
Three, you think?
Can you carry doggies?
What's your rank?
I didn't...
Okay, do you want to try?
Okay, sure.
Okay.
Let's come up here.
Come up here.
Give some applause to the two of you.
Yeah!
Okay, let me ask you a question.
This is a very interesting question.
Are you Thomas?
Yes, I am Thomas.
I am Thomas.
Poor Thomas.
I am Jason.
His name is Jason.
Jason.
Okay, give some...
Give some applause to Jason.
Okay.
Yeah!
Jason.
Hi.
Please be seated.
Okay.
Put your luggage under the seat and fasten your seat belt.
Fasten your seat belt.
Okay, may I know your name?
May I know your name?
Ryder.
Oh, his name is Ryder.
Can you speak Cantonese?
What's your rank?
Okay.
His Cantonese is...
Yes, this is you.
Okay.
No problem.
You can speak English.
So...
All right, guys.
Who's going to be carrying this time?
Yeah.
I think...
But like actually carrying.
All right.
Who's to carry?
He said he's not paying for free season, but he's confident to carry you out.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Who?
Jason?
Is it Jason?
Alright Jason, play Wraith.
Play Wraith?
I play Vantage though.
Okay Jason, play Vantage.
Wait, you're not Jason.
He's Jason!
Oh, this is Jason?
Sorry, I got my names mixed up.
Alright Jason, play Vantage.
Alright.
This is a terrible squad, but like, that's okay.
This is a terrible comp, but that's okay.
The comp is the weirdest comp I've ever seen.
A Loba, Lifeline, and Vantage.
We have no escapability, but that's okay.
Wait, Loba, ready up!
Do you have anything you want to tell Doki?
I'm very nervous right now.
It's okay.
I believe in you guys.
We can only go up after what happened.
We can only go up.
Alright, we just need one more person to ready up.
Yeah, it's almost ready.
There's a little bit of setting we are doing right now.
Oh, okay.
Oh, setting adjustments?
Yes, setting adjustments.
Okay.
Alright, let's do it.
What are you going to choose?
Hey, what are you going to play?
Fuse or maybe Fusey.
Fuse or Caustic.
Okay.
Yeah, you know what?
That works.
Vantage, Lifeline, Caustic.
We're just going to stay in a house until top three.
Just like Rank, I guess.
Alright.
Who's Jump Master?
Because it's not me.
I never jump.
Ooh.
I have confidence in this team.
I mean, like, you can't do worse than Thomas.
Like...
Never mind.
I think I forgot to change my character.
Ah, no, wait.
Oh, no, no.
You can change the character.
Wait a minute.
How...
We can change the character.
Did you lie about your credentials?
I forgot to change my character?
There's a character select screen that's been here for four years.
Let me transfer for you.
Alright.
Don't worry, Vantage.
I'll give all my support to you.
I won't go too fast this time.
The audience is also being praised.
Can they have some fun?
Okay.
So, yeah.
I'm bringing you guys to really hard lobbies, just so you guys know.
I'm bringing...
These lobbies are a lot more difficult than usual.
Alright.
Vantage.
Take us to the place.
The fight.
No sightseeing.
I wanna fight.
Where do I go?
Look at the sign.
Okay.
Jason, where are you gonna go?
Alright.
This must be what a bullet feels like.
Let's see.
I'm trying to see if there's any teens with us.
I can see that Jason's really pulled.
He doesn't seem...
Oh, he knows how to do the dolphin.
Even though we don't need to do the dolphin, because we're right here.
What are you doing here, Caustic?
Leave.
This is my spot.
Mine.
Okay.
You have better ping.
That's not fair.
That's...
Do you... Okay.
I'm not shooting my gun if you're gonna take all of it.
Alright.
Is there a team here?
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, hello.
I'm here for the loot, too.
Caustic took everything.
Yeah.
Let's go.
200 ping flatline is not great.
Jason!
There's nobody here!
What's wrong with the settings?
Wait.
Hold on.
There's nobody here!
I'm working on it.
Trust.
He's working on it.
He's coming.
There's nobody here!
Enter the ring.
Shut up.
Follow me.
Oh!
Whoa!
He's trying.
I bet you guys he's gonna die first, guys.
Alright.
Oh!
We're getting our ult here.
Yeah.
Come on, Caustic!
We're gonna get our ult.
Oh!
I guess we're not getting ult.
It's okay, he doesn't need it.
He doesn't need it if he's not fast enough.
He doesn't get it.
Come on
Let's get our package might as well
Well, okay, there's a redeploy over there Let's go I Don't think there's I think there might be a team there could be a team in containment.
There's always a team there
This is no loot here.
Oh, no, it was looted.
This is looted That mean there's a team near us Oh waiting Is that person oh, yes, there's a person here right in front of me
Oh There's one look at him.
He doesn't know he's doing Fossa you going first come on.
Don't be don't be scared.
Come on.
Come on Go out go in he's clearly flesh come on costing you have
But don't die
Behind you Vantage
Your caustic I Don't have needs though.
So that dead Oh behind us.
Oh Flash flash flash live
This is it you have to carry he's right here hanging right here in the open it's so easy Oh He's right Oh mutas teammates teammate teammate teammate.
Oh No, this is it you said you're a carrier oh That's another team sorry, we just got third party Okay, I'm your own brum lifeline I have no escape ability, okay Okay Let's do one more.
All right now I'll actually try This time I was just messing about guys
I'll try for real now no more messing about no more trolling One more time chance, okay
Yeah, he's really focused I could tell he's gaming right now Let's do a real cop It's a little hard to play cuz I'm not familiar with these key bindings Oh, wait you have to play the game?
I guess there's melee I guess there's melee Just a melee one.
I can't do it.
I don't get different on this one.
Yeah Don't wear I believe in you guys I got a bit of chance Yeah Oh Yeah Okay, let's not let's not hot drop this time Please let's see.
Are we landing?
Oh here?
All right, do it
See you forgot how sweaty Asia servers are at this time I'm so used to playing Asia servers that like my prime time.
So it'd be like 3 in the morning in Hong Kong All right, we should rotate up here after And see we can third-party somebody Is that's what apex is all about
Yeah Oh
Massive on 200 ping is not fun, so I'm gonna throw that gun away Feed me carbine and I I guess vault.
Okay, that's not a carbine.
That's...
Oh, there's a vault here.
Oh, nice.
Alright, got my load out.
Alright guys, we can do this.
We can at least get top 10, guys.
Let's win our first team fight.
Like, very low goal.
But like, if we win our first team fight, we're real winners.
I'm gonna head up now.
Top 20.
Oh shit, we're not last!
Let's go!
Alright.
Let's go this way, guys.
We should be fine, right?
I mean, we have white armor, but like, it can't be that bad.
I mean, everybody...
Whoever survives this area tends to be like blue armor, but that's alright.
Alright.
Um...
Where?
Oh, there they are.
Don't really see them.
Oh, all the way back there?
Oh, okay.
Where?
Oh, there!
He's right here.
Let's see.
There's a team fight here in front of me.
There's a rev.
Oh, he's down already.
Let's back up a little.
I'm backing up a little bit, guys.
There's two team fights here.
There's two teams here.
I'll feel safe about that.
Ooh, nice shot!
Let's see...
Climb me up.
Bye.
Over there.
You know what, you don't deserve to live.
On me.
I think.
I'm lying.
Okay.
Nice.
Look guys, we did it!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
There's another guy.
No he doesn't.
Jason, he's right behind you.
Oh!
Your controller?
He's flesh!
Nice.
See?
You guys don't need help.
You're fine.
Alright.
Who's the roller?
Is that you?
That's right, play Mimik.
To actually be a good player.
Alright.
Is there another?
I think there's one more team up there.
There's like 20 teams here.
Let's go check it out guys.
If I die, I die.
Alright, let's see if we cleared the area.
Hey, top 10!
If we live for five more squads, we did the best.
Oh, I don't have a grenade.
I'm gonna go get a grenade.
Top five.
Top five, let's go!
I believe in us!
Let's see.
I don't see anybody.
I guess we can leave.
I think everybody died.
Yippee!
Oh.
There's a container here.
Oh, look at them.
Somebody died to ring.
Not us.
Alright.
Most likely, there could be a team in containment, so let's go over there.
There's always a certain rotation for teams.
Every team will either be in containment or like, market.
I don't know why.
I guess people just like being in containment or market.
Nice, we need that 3x.
Alright, guys.
Oh, see!
I told you!
I heard shots!
Wait.
Yeah, see!
Every time.
Containment or market.
I might get shot.
I have no idea where.
Where they went.
Where did they go?
What?
Wait.
Am I gaslighting myself?
I thought I...
Where are they?
Wait, no!
We have Bloodhound!
Bloodhound, do the thing!
Go do the thing, Bloodhound!
Alright, I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna grab the Evo Harvester.
Guys, we just need one team to die and then we can...
We did it.
We made it.
Alright, what do your Specialized see?
Okay, they're all... Oh my god, they're all in runoff.
Okay, let's go to runoff.
We don't have to care about this team.
They'll just kill themselves, I guess.
So, we'll go over here.
They're so far from zone anyway.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, everybody's at...
Heading to...
Heading to runoff fight.
Oh, I see them!
No, I don't have a redeploy!
Alright.
Let's go!
We did it by doing absolutely nothing!
Alright,
I'll wait for you guys.
I'm not stupid enough to go in by myself.
They're like over there.
So I'll wait for...
No, I'll wait for Jason.
Alright, let's go.
I don't hear gunshots, which is what concerns me.
Oh!
Now that's a mirage, isn't that?
That's a mirage.
There's no way he would just stand there.
Where are they?
Alright, Bloodhound!
You know where...
Where they are?
You see foots... Oh, right here!
Right here!
In front of you!
Oh, whoops.
You guys didn't see that.
Oh!
But you guys saw that, right?
Alright, here's my ult.
My ult!
Oh...
Where are they?
Oh, they're over here.
Right here.
I think that's the only team, right?
Yeah.
They're all the way over there.
They're heading down?
Am I in zone?
I'm not.
They're like here.
I don't like... I'm gonna get across, Angla.
I see them.
All the way over here.
That's a mirage.
Never mind.
I lied.
What?
Okay, I'm gonna do something really stupid.
Oh!
Help him!
That's another team!
Another team!
I got you!
Another team over there, behind us.
Oh, god damn it!
Mirage!
Um...
I smoked him.
I have nothing for you?
Yeah, but I had to deal with a guy above me!
Oh!
New team!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Up top.
We can be underneath this.
I'm looking.
There is a team that shot me from behind.
Oh, they have a crypto.
Okay, that's not good for us.
Alright!
Definitely not good.
I got hit.
Oh, god.
Okay.
I'm gonna go into this hole.
This is my hole.
This hole is very safe, by the way.
I rotated.
Let's see.
Keep crawling!
Keep crawling to our bloodhound!
I'll cover!
Fuse!
Where's fuse?
Ping!
Ping it!
Okay, that is...
Where did you come from?
Giving him the chimney.
Give him my shield of recharge.
Alright, guys.
Do any of you have redeploy?
None of us have redeploy.
Okay.
Haha!
Uh...
We might be the people that die in zone.
We have to go to zone.
Top three.
Hey, top three!
Over here?
Wait, are you guys getting shot at?
Oh, by them.
I'm safe here?
Not really, but like...
I tried.
I wanna get the other two teams to fight.
This safe.
Come here.
Okay.
Let's see.
Uh...
Yeah.
Let's do it!
I'll use my bat.
Whoa!
He broke the shield!
Go do that thing!
Keep doing that!
I'm gonna push closer.
Wait, they're fighting!
Go, go, go, go, go!
They're fighting!
We third party!
This is it!
This is our shine!
Shining moment!
On me!
No, I'm on me!
JK!
Don't listen to me!
I was lying!
They stopped fighting!
These nerds!
Okay, I'm getting cross-angled.
You guys see where you are?
Yeah, see where you are!
I'm gonna get cross-angled.
Yeah, yeah.
They're getting harassed by us.
And the other team.
So that's good.
I cracked so many people.
I'm pushing up.
You don't have to push up.
It's your choice, honestly.
Oh!
No!
It's okay.
Don't ignore.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no!
That is very ballsy, but okay.
Cover us!
If you cover us, this could be fine.
Okay.
Alright.
What do your eyes see?
Okay, I'm coming back to you guys.
Knocked.
I thirsted him.
I'm medicating.
There's a body right there.
Oh, okay.
Crypto, I hope you have a very bad day after this.
Yeah, I can.
There you go.
Let's see.
It's a full team!
Over here where I'm looking at.
There's a team that has a cross on me.
Oh, it's a Mirage.
Okay.
Whoa.
You guys are not fun.
Oh, here's a f- Oh!
Hey, I think we're dead!
Hey, but we made it!
We got top two!
It's all about the top two, baby!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Screw you.
Oh, you're bad!
You guys are so bad!
We got top two, though!
I was in!
Look, we did pretty well.
We did pretty- I did not expect us to ever get top five, let alone top two.
You want to stay the doggy?
I saw you carry everyone.
You're so good.
Yeah?
I'm a red planet Jankton, okay?
What a carry!
You want something to doggy?
Oh, yeah, we did great.
It's all the hardware's problem, not us.
We were great.
Yeah, blame the PC, of course.
Yeah, it's ping, too.
The PC should be better, that's all I'm gonna say.
Do something!
I don't care about it!
Thank you so much, Les.
I'm gonna go back to the stage.
Let's- Yeah, it's not a- Yes, it's always hardware, guys.
You know what?
You're right.
My PC could be better, too.
So intense watching you guys playing.
It's like I'm sweating already on my back.
Oh, yeah, that was intense.
I did not expect- I did not expect the games to be that sweaty.
Let's do some more chilling things.
I wanted some questions I wanted to ask you.
Yeah.
About Hong Kong.
So, I know you guys have played- living in Hong Kong before, right?
Mm-hmm.
What's the most food that you're missing in Hong Kong?
Like, eating?
Oh, it's just rice noodles and fish balls.
Fish balls and rice noodles.
You know what to prepare, right?
Rice noodles and fish balls.
Okay, next time.
Also, like, there's a restaurant I don't know if a lot of people will go now, but there's a restaurant I really like called Tomato Club.
Not because I like tomatoes, but because it's really good.
Basically, it's like- I like to put any toppings on it.
For tomato soup, it's really good.
In Hong Kong?
Yeah, it's in Hong Kong!
I've didn't try this.
They have a franchise in Hong Kong.
It's called Tomato Club.
You have to take me there next time.
I've never tried it.
It's really good.
I'm really missing it.
Okay, so the second question is, what do you know about Anycorn or Comic-Con?
What do you actually bought in Anycorn or Comic-Con?
What did you buy?
When I was younger, I used to buy figures.
Nendoroid.
I really like buying Nendoroid.
At ACGHK.
And I really like to visit- You guys don't call it Artist Alley, but other places.
But there are a lot of small artists who put things on the shelves and buy things.
I really like buying their stuff.
I used to buy a lot of Madoka stuff.
What did they buy this time?
What's popular this time?
Oh, it's a gold medal!
I bought your hat.
Yes, I bought your hat.
I know what I buy in Comic-Con this time.
Next year, we still need to buy your products, okay?
It's so true.
So, for the fourth question, I'm going to ask your fans, the dragoons, what they want to ask you and talk with you.
Like doing some more chilling section.
So I'm going down and choosing some audience right now.
Okay, let's go down and interview everyone.
Did you choose the question section?
Does anyone want to ask a question?
Do you have any questions you want to ask the doggies?
Who wants to ask me a question?
Let's go back to the studio.
Okay, I will ask this pretty lady first.
What's your question?
You made a song in Augustra.
When did you use that song?
When did I use it?
I didn't use it.
She made a lot of different songs for the first time.
I don't know.
I was going to post it on YouTube.
But I was going to commission an animation for the song.
I don't want to just post it like this.
So I'm waiting for a I'm thinking of what story for the animation for the song.
I don't know.
I really don't know.
I have a lot of songs and I don't know what to do.
What's your question?
Hello, my name is Isaac.
I want to ask you a question.
I want to ask you a question about if you were going back to Hong Kong, what's the first thing you would do in Hong Kong?
What's the first thing?
Going to Mong Kok.
I miss Mong Kok.
I love going there.
If you go to Mong Kok, you can get fish roe and rice noodles.
Yes, yes.
And there are a lot of things to buy.
I always go to Mong Kok to buy.
And Hong Kong's Disney.
Oh, I see.
I heard they have a lot of new things in Hong Kong.
Let me choose one more.
There are.
Both sides have it.
So many questions.
We don't talk with you so much.
We miss you so much.
The question is Do you miss 5v5 or 6v6 Overwatch?
6v6 Overwatch.
Okay.
I had a big rant about it.
But like if we do 6v6 again for Overwatch with the tanks, how busted the tanks are now?
Like, you know, with their 10,000 HP and 50,000 damage.
Like Zarya with any other tank.
I think like if they don't nerf the tanks, we are so...
I'm trying to like filter myself here because I have so many things I could say.
But there's children here.
But I would love 6v6.
But the current situation with the tank being like raid boss level 5v5 is the most optimal right now.
Also, we don't care about what DPS feels.
DPS, you had no opinion in this game for five years now.
So I'm sorry.
Especially Pharah players.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Look at this loser still playing Pharah in 2024.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Let me come back to the stage again.
So Dokie, I know that after Q&A question and we played very intense Apex game, we have some little chilling mini game with your friends again, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's still not the end.
There's one last game, guys.
I believe I teach you the Chinese name yesterday.
Do you remember the name?
The game name?
Oh, Dokiewa.
Yes.
It's like Simon Says.
Yes, it's actually Simon Says.
So we're going to choose 10 fans come up here for participation to the Dokiewa.
Let me let you by section.
I will choose five here and five over there.
Okay?
I don't even know if that's like a good thing getting chosen.
Yes.
The guy with glasses on the back is the one in the high heels.
Hi.
Welcome to the stage.
Welcome to the stage, everybody.
Okay.
One by one.
Let's line up in a straight line.
Okay.
That's about it.
What's your name?
My name is Sasa.
How do you...
Okay.
He's saying in English.
You see my dad today.
Oh, he's called Sasa.
Oh my God.
Look, there's dad.
Yes.
Okay.
What's your name?
Sarah.
She's Sarah.
Just call me Peg.
He's Peg.
Okay, Peg.
What's your name?
Lai Min.
Her name is Lai Min.
Okay.
What's your name?
I'm Jace.
Okay.
Nice.
What's your name?
Yasumi.
Okay.
Nice to meet you.
What's your name?
Matthew.
Jeffy.
Call me Aaron.
Scallop.
So, Doggy, do you remember all your names already?
Yeah.
I forgot like half your names.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, me too.
So, do you guys all know how to play Do-Ki-Wa?
It's what Simon says.
I don't know how to play.
Can you raise your hand?
Okay, I'll say it again.
Do-Ki-Wa is actually Simon's say.
Do-Ki will give you a command later.
Every time he says Do-Ki-Wa, you have to follow his command to do the command.
For example, I'll demo it now.
Do-Ki-Wa, raise both hands.
Put your hands down.
I didn't say Do-Ki-Wa.
Okay, now put your hands down.
Do-Ki-Wa, put your hands down.
Okay, everyone get ready.
Okay, I trained them already.
Do-Ki, it's your turn.
It's your turn.
Sure, okay.
Do-Ki-Wa 2.
Do -Ki-Wa 2.
Who?
Who jumped?
Okay, you jumped.
Okay, we'll do it again.
We'll do it again.
Okay, how many people left?
Seven left.
One, two, three, start.
Do-Ki-Wa 2.
Do -Ki -Wa, get on your knees.
Okay, turn around.
Do-Ki-Wa, turn around.
You're too much.
Okay, Do-Ki-Wa, bow.
Yes!
Okay, everyone stand up.
Oh, no one is standing up.
They're so good.
They're so good at this.
They're so good at the game already.
Do -Ki-Wa, stand up.
Okay, Do-Ki-Wa 2.
Do-Ki-Wa 2.
Two.
Oh!
That was so good.
I feel like that's like the easiest way to get people off the stage.
Okay.
Alright, there's six left.
Okay, Jing-Wan.
Okay, do-ki-wa.
Do-ki-wa.
Do-ki-wa, Jing-Wan.
Sorry, again.
Oh, people didn't tune!
Sorry, sorry, the voice is not so good.
Can you do it again?
Oh, okay.
Do-ki-wa, Jing-Wan.
Okay.
Do-ki-wa.
Do-ki-wa, what is it?
Oh my god.
I didn't think all of you guys were going to survive here.
Okay, there's too many people left.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Do-ki-wa.
Compliment me.
Look at me.
Do-ki-wa.
Oh, wait.
Okay, do-ki-wa.
Compliment me.
Tell the world why you love me so much.
Actually, everyone is doing it.
I'm checking.
They're doing good.
Do-ki-wa.
Tell the world why you love me so much.
I'm checking.
You're so creative.
Keep going.
Okay.
Do-ki-wa.
Do.
I did that three times.
How are you still getting eliminated?
We only kill half people, Do-ki.
Okay.
MC, give me ideas.
What should I ask them to do?
Okay, let's go to the last round.
This is the last round.
Last round?
Oh my god.
Wait, you didn't give me the ideas.
Do-ki-wa, please.
Give it to me
Give it to me Give it to me Oh my gosh, what can you do while you're sitting down?
You can't do anything Give it to me, Pachae Clap Keep clapping Give it to me, Pachae
And then there were two Wait, wait, wait Last one, I have something No, no, you didn't say Dokihwa Stand up, they're still sitting on the floor Okay, K-Sun Dokihwa, K-Sun Alright Let's do the final round Let's do it, okay Dokihwa Clap Dokihwa, keep clapping Stop Keep clapping No They wanna win Dokihwa,
two Continue, two
Dokihwa One more, two Dokihwa, continue, one more, two Stop Stop Hey, why are you stopping?
Stop Stop Dokihwa, stop Dokihwa, stop Dokihwa, two Dokihwa, stop Dokihwa, two Stop Stop
Dokihwa, two Dokihwa, two Dokihwa, two dc Dc
born Dc from Please give you Give her some applause, she's already dancing very hard We're doing sports Today's sports is dancing We're going to invite the players to come together and take a group photo
Show me your love Show me your love for Dokie 1, 2, 3
Oh my gosh, this is the longest photo ever Thank you I was like, is this a video instead of a photo?
I think we got everything Yeah That's great I had a great time I got a great time telling people what to do It's my favorite part
Guys, I'm definitely not sleeping after this I drank two cans of coffee Guys, I'm so My sleep schedule is going to be so messed up Guys I have something on my hand right now Oh, what's that?
I just got like some badges on my hand Oh Do you want to pass it to your friends?
For your friends?
We can just give over there But I only have like 10 over here So Battle Royale, let's go How do we choose the audience?
The strongest dragoon gets the little gift The strongest dragoon gets the little gift How can I choose which one I want to go to Give the gifts I choose?
Yeah, maybe Oh, I pick?
It's you, it's not me Me?
I was just going to say throw it in the air and see who ever gets it Oh no Throw it to the crowd Let me give the first question Show me the most love of your face Do doki for me Like some some I want the most creative love Oh my gosh The most creative love Let me see She even loves her feet She even loves her feet Yeah,
she loves her feet Okay, it's your turn Turn doki One question One question for them Okay, me?
One question for them?
Yes, ask something You want them to know And they should know I think Oh, something that they should know About me?
Oh, so I'm testing them Yes, testing how they love you Alright, okay Oh my gosh This is going to be difficult What can I test them?
Okay Oh my gosh, now you're putting me on the spot
I'm like, what do I know about myself?
Oh, yeah What's my birthday?
Okay One, two, three This one, the one with the glasses This one is really fast Wait, not everybody raised their head?
Four for July Four for July So this month is your birthday month Oh my gosh, I can't believe Not every dragoon raised their hand When I said when my birthday is That's messed up Okay, so I think we can give to Those who are just playing games with us Yeah Wait,
who has not got anything?
We should give something for someone who hasn't got anything yet Yeah All the people here already got everything from you Oh, you guys already got everything?
Okay You guys don't matter Also, you all laughed at me already You guys already got stuff We're going to give it to other people who didn't get anything We're all about equality here We're all about equality here We're all about equality here Okay I have two more Two more?
Throw it into the crowd!
Who said that?
To the audience, okay?
I'll give you a little Throw it into the crowd!
To my fans Yeah!
Throw it into the crowd!
It's like a marriage flower If you get it, congratulations, you're going to get married Woo!
Oh my god, round eight!
Yay!
You guys are like celebrities Yeah!
You guys are like concert stars Hahaha There's no sound here
One, two This is from Doki, okay?
One, two, three Yay!
Oh!
Someone spiked it out of their hands I want the guy to help me throw it I'm not strong enough The guy is throwing it Whoever gets it is going to get married One, two, three!
Wow!
Okay, okay, this side This side, this side I think this side is quiet Hahaha But Sandy wants to call you Free stuff, free stuff Free stuff, free stuff Free stuff, free stuff She's talking again Okay, okay, be stronger Comrades, comrades, one, two, three Throw it at Piu Okay Yay!
Thank you comrades Okay, so It's almost the end It's almost the end?
Yeah, do you have something you want to talk with your friends?
Oh, I want to say Thank you to all my family Invite me to ACGHK It's serious It's so crazy It's so crazy To talk with so many people And so many Hong Kong fans And play with them So thank you guys so much everybody Also buy my merch Hahaha Hahaha I have merch at There's merch at F36 It seems like It seems like,
right?
F36 Guys it's 4.30am My memory is not good right now So if you want to buy any of my merch Exclusive Hong Kong merch is at F36 And if you have any gifts for me Gifts or letters You can leave at F36 And they will send it to you And I will take it And if you leave a gift You get 50 years of good luck Because you know I grant you 50 years of good luck And so anytime something good happens to you It's because of me Just remember that Hahaha Okay,
thank you Doki It's so lovely to have you here today And we have a very nice time So last thing is that We want to take a picture together with our Camera over there Let's take a picture with everyone
Let's all take a photo Let's all take a photo Can you see it?
I'm looking at it the wrong way Hahaha Let's take a picture with the one with the high hand The one with the low hand is on camera Oh my god Who is holding the camera?
One, two, three Oh my god
Can you see it?
Yeah Oh my god Okay one more thing I want to do for you I have one gift for you Another camera over there Right?
This is a video man I want everyone turn to the video And count to three Say Doki we love you Okay?
Are you ready?
One, two, three Doki we love you Doki we love you
Oh my god Oh my god The camera man actually showed me How many people are there And I was like that's a lot of people Yes it's a lot of people So thank you very much for coming today We're looking forward to see you soon Thank you for inviting me Hong Kong I'm so happy to be here Give Doki one more round of applause Thank you everyone See you next time Bye bye Doki Hope to see you guys again soon in the future We also have a fan meeting soon I think Hahaha Okay let's say bye bye Doki Bye bye Bye bye everybody Bye bye everyone Okay
Thank you for coming Please be careful If you are a singer Please be careful when you leave the stage Bye bye everyone